so this is going to be a very different
type of video we're going to talk about
time management there are a million ways
to do this but we're going to talk about
the way that I do it specifically I
found one way that works really well for
me so I became self-employed this last
January and one of the quickest things
that appeared to me is that it's a big
deal to know how to manage your time and
really you have a two-fold problem one
you have to create and prioritize your
goals and deadlines and on the other
hand you have to have a way to manage
your time such that you achieve those
goals and deadlines in a timely manner
and here's a fair disclaimer my system
might not work for you but the important
thing is to take what you find useful
here apply it to whatever you do and
just leave the rest all right so let's
get into it I do three main things to
manage my time number one I just have a
planner you know this is pretty
boilerplate just to record any kind of
trip appointment meaning something
time-sensitive that I need to do there's
not much else to say there number two I
block out my day into 15-minute
increments and fill them out as the day
goes I got this idea from the venture
capitalist Mike Jackson who is featured
in the book so good they can't ignore
you the reason for doing this is that I
can create a snapshot of what my day
looked like and I can see what I spent
all my time on so I usually fill in the
sheet whenever I complete a major task
so if editing this video took me from 12
p.m. to 4 p.m. I'll just fill in those
blocks all at once and I use colors to
designate that if you create your own
version of this you're going to have to
make your own buckets that are relevant
to your life so at the beginning of each
day it looks like this and by the end of
it it looks like this and at this point
I use a little macro that I created to
count of all the 15-minute increments so
I can see that oh I spent you know this
percent working out today I spent this
percent reading etc then we put in the
date and hit this button which saves the
file into this time archive folder which
I have which I'll show you right here
what's really cool about this is that
after doing it for like four months now
I can look back on any given day of
those four months and I can see exactly
what I was doing
at any given time during the day which
is really cool and this brings us full
circle to number three and number three
I have review periods where I see how
much of my goals I shaved what my
progress was and how much of my week or
month or whatever review period I'm
doing how much of that month was
dedicated to the right things how much
of it could have been better allocated
somewhere else
etc basically I'm looking to see what I
did right and what I did wrong and what
I can achieve better next time this is a
super underrated thing people think that
just because your time is in the past
you should never look back you should
absolutely look back all good time
management systems should have some type
of review system to see how you actually
did anytime that you add in any extra
thing some kind of goal some kind of you
know you want to try running once a week
you have to know how you did and so
that's what this allows you to do so in
this sample week you can see how much I
read how much it worked out how much
time I wasted the percentage of my week
that it all took up and this is super
powerful to let you know where you can
improve if you think oh man I spend more
time on that than I thought I'm going to
move that over here you could do that so
that's pretty much it
this time management system has been
absolutely essential to me and I think
if you're an entrepreneur or you're
somebody who is self-employed or just
you know anybody who's very serious
about their time I think something like
this would really help you out so I'm
going to lead my daily spreadsheets as
well as my review spreadsheets in the
links below with all the macros already
in them and I'm going to create a second
video to explain how to use them if
you're interested also if you want to
learn more go check out David Allen's
getting things done plenty of people
have found him
as well okay that's all for now be sure
to comment if you have a system that
already works for you you can subscribe
if you like the content check out the
next video here where I explain all my
spreadsheets and thank you guys so much
for watching I will see you next week
with another coffee break